[Music]
on this Monday night desperation in
Gaza the Scramble for dwindling supplies
the hospitals overwhelmed by Israel
Siege and the Canadians trying to help
all the time we would just see civilians
coming in and out either coming in
injured or out in body bags Israel under
pressure as President Biden cautions it
could make a big mistake aggressive
Maneuvers a Chinese fighter J that's
Brazen intercept of a Canadian Force's
plane our Neu Garo was on board it is
within a few meters of the wing L
seeking Sanctuary the small Church in
Gaza welcoming Palestinians trying to
find
protection global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us the Israeli Siege of Gaza is
making conditions more dire by the hour
and for a second second day promises a
border crossing would open to allow in
humanitarian Aid failed to happen
civilians who cannot Escape Gaza now
caught in this siege for N9 days Israel
has not begun its land Invasion but its
air strikes and its Siege cutting off
food power water and medical supplies is
killing people the Gaza Health Ministry
says more than 2,700 people have died
almost 10,000 are injured Gaza the UN
says is being strangled the World Health
Organization says the lives of more than
3,500 patients in 35 hospitals in Gaza
are at immediate risk and called for the
unobstructed access of humanitarian Aid
at the Rafa Border Crossing into Egypt
today no one got out and none of the
trucks on the Egyptian side filled with
humanitarian Aid got in Israel has vowed
to wipe out Hamas the islamist group
that controls Gaza and which brutally
killed 1400 Israelis wiping out entire
families burning their homes and taking
hostages we have complete coverage
tonight on events in Washington Ottawa
Israel and Gaza We Begin tonight with
Jeff simple in Jerusalem
Jeff Donna the UN the World Health
Organization and practically every major
Aid organization in this region are
sounding the alarm tonight Gaza is out
of
time gaza's healthc care system is on
the verge of collapse it's falling apart
uh in every uh kind of Junction in in
the system the UN warns in the coming
hours hospitals in Gaza will run out of
fuel they're also dangerously low on
water medicine even staff in total
Israel has killed 14 doctors and 13
nurses the staff a lot of them have lost
their homes a lot of them have lost
family members Dr Hassan Abu told Global
News the water pressure in his hospital
is so low they can no longer sterilize
their equipment Israel said Sunday it
was rest starting the supply of water
but only to Southern Gaza have you heard
anything about uh whether that the water
has been restored or something no I'm
drinking like some kind of salty water
from a well right now this Canadian and
his family are trapped in Gaza he's
volunteering at a hospital where he's
witnessed horrific scenes today in theun
hospital where I'm at right now a child
was overlooking their dead parents and
telling them hey Mom and Dad let's go
back home you know I'm ready why are we
still asleep
and that what child doesn't know that
he's not going to have a mom to take
care of anymore or a father to race his
family followed Israel's evacuation
order last week leaving their home in
Northern Gaza to head south and avoid
becoming caught in gun battles from
Israel's imminent ground Invasion even
in the South he says they're still being
bombed and now they're stuck along with
thousands of others near the Egyptian
border no one getting out and no Aid
getting in 80% of Gins before this
crisis we're dependent on Aid uh we can
assume that 100% of the population will
need this Aid as in dire need of water
of fuel of food hundreds of tons of Aid
and supplies are stuck on the Egyptian
side of the Border Egypt and Aid groups
blaming Israeli air strikes so Israel
can open the Border tomorrow and can
allow relief and that's primarily is the
Israeli responsibility
in response to calls for a ceasefire
Israel's prime minister's office
published this tur statement there is
currently no ceasefire and humanitarian
Aid in the Gaza Strip in exchange for
the expulsion of foreigners the UN
agency responsible for Palestinian
refugees also said it had received
reports that Hamas had seized
humanitarian supplies from a un compound
in Gaza City after publishing that
statement on its website and on social
media the UN agency then deleted the
post they wouldn't say why but in Gaza
speaking out against Hamas can be deadly
Donna all right Jeff simple in Jerusalem
thanks it is Palestinians who live in
Gaza but Israel controls almost
everything and everyone who goes in and
out the Rafa gate is the only Lifeline
now it's at the southernmost end of Gaza
and borders Egypt Sinai Peninsula a
desert the only other way out is the arz
Crossing in the North controlled by
Israel and Kem shalom in the South
though it's used solely for commercial
Goods both are shut Rafa is where most
Palestinians try to get permission to
exit but Egypt tightly controls it and
approval is difficult most people born
in Gaza have never
left a Canadian born artillery officer
is helping plan Israel's ground
offensive into Gaza Chrystal ganing is
in Jerusalem and has been speaking with
her
Crystal Donna May told me that she
rushed back to Israel she was on
vacation in Canada when that deadly
incursion by Hamas took place on October
7th right now she describes her work as
very intense as she's helping to craft
Israel's ground offensive work that puts
the lives of soldiers and civilians in
her
hands a buildup of troops and tanks can
be seen outside Gaza as Israel readies
itself for a military operation
officials claim will eliminate
Hamas we are focused on one goal to get
forces and go forward to victory for
this purpose we will need determination
says Benjamin Netanyahu addressing the
knesset the Israeli Prime Minister told
parliamentarians Victory will take
time around Israel military hardware is
on the Move several days have passed
since the nation warned the world it
would be launching coordinated attacks
including a significant ground operation
there's a lot of people that I haven't
seen in a while an operation this isra
reservice originally from Toronto will
be helping to design Global News has
agreed to only use Maya's first name and
not show her face because of the nature
of her work we plan all of the military
targets um this is a huge role as you
can imagine especially dealing with all
of the international onlookers and and
and explaining and also doing everything
according to Israeli law as well as
international law people Mayo was
sitting in a synagogue in Vancouver with
her husband when the rabbi started to
explain that Hamas Fighters stormed into
Israel terrorizing communities taking
hostages and eventually killing more
than 1,300 people nauseous sick to my
stomach couldn't even imagine the
horrors that that people had gone
through and that people were still going
through she says she's angry to see how
some people are reacting to what she
views as Israel defending itself the UN
says many women and children have been
killed in air strikes Maya says Israel
takes precautions to warn citizens and
minimize the loss of Civilian lives we
don't want to kill people especially not
people who are not involved in the
situation we are simply protecting
ourselves but Hamas has also been
planning and is likely ready for an
allout of assault by Israel says this
security expert they have been ruling
hamama ruling Gaza and it's a town they
have a town underground um that they are
in control of not the Israeli Army and
undoubtedly they're setting traps for
the Israeli soldiers Security Experts
and military strategists anticipate a
long and bloody war we did hear the
Prime Minister say that determination
and time will be needed for victory but
Maya is confident they will succeed in
their objectives and ensure Israel's
security Donna crystal ganing in
Jerusalem thanks Crystal intense
diplomatic efforts are underway to try
to limit the humanitarian crisis plus
avoid this expanding into a wider
conflict in the region and late today it
was announced the American President Joe
Biden will travel to the region and is
expected to meet with Israel's prime
minister Jackson prco is with me from
Washington Jackson tell us the
significance of this
trip well Donna this gives you a sense
of the role that the Americans are
playing in all this the announcement
about President Biden's visit on
Wednesday came after a marathon 7 and a
half hour long session between US
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin and
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and it was at the end of that
that we heard the announcement that
Biden will travel to the region on
Wednesday on the agenda is that Biden
will hear personally from the Israelis
what their plan is what their objectives
are for the ground invasion of Gaza as
well as what their plan is for
minimizing civili ion casualties the US
also says it has Israeli agreement to
try and open up some sort of
humanitarian Corridor try and make sure
that aid from other governments and NOS
makes it inside of Gaza although the
specifics still have to be announced
there one thing to keep in mind here is
that the visit of a president of course
is a huge security and logistical
problem it could potentially delay The
Invasion uh if one does take place in
Gaza it seems unlikely that would start
while Biden is on the ground the other
thing to keep in mind here Donna is that
this comes as part of a broader us
increase in posture in the region a
second aircraft carrier is on the way to
the Eastern Mediterranean and there are
reports that as many as 2,000 Marines
are also being stationed offshore as a
potential rapid reaction force should
they be needed at some point Donna many
developments and more specifics to come
out in the days ahead but certainly a
major announcement tonight about the
president's looming visit lots of moving
Parts Jackson prco in Washington thank
you beyond the Middle East there were
tense moments for a Canadian military
Patrol aircraft operating as part of a
multinational force in international
airspace off the coast of China Chinese
Jets intercepted that plane using
Maneuvers senior military officials
describe as aggressive Global's Neu Gara
was on board the Canadian plane and
explains what
happened a Chinese jet carrying
air-to-air missiles was doing what major
General Ian Huddleston describes as
dangerous Maneuvers within close
proximity to a Canadian military plane
they became very uh very aggressive and
um and to a degree that we would deem it
unsafe and
unprofessional he said the Chinese jet
also launched multiple flares near the
front of the Canadian plane causing
further concern it happened on Monday in
international airspace off the coast of
China this Chinese fighter jet
intercepting this Canadian Armed Forces
Aurora plane is within a few meters of
the wing it was as close as uh 10 to 20
ft Global News was on board the Canadian
Aurora aircraft reporting on operation
neon part of Canada's contribution to
enforce sanctions against North Korea by
documenting ships believed to be
carrying illegal oil shipments we're not
here acting against the Chinese we don't
want to have anything unto word happen
that would that that would result in the
loss of life the reason for the
aggressive intercepts is unknown the
Canadian crew says they've remained in
international waters and are
communicating with Chinese Pilots
letting them know who they are and what
they're doing I am a Canadian aircraft
conducting Patrol in support of United
Nations regulations National Defense
Minister Bill Blair called the Chinese
military actions unacceptable I am very
concerned that the the unprofessional
way in which this was done it was quite
frankly dangerous and Reckless and put
our aircraft and their mission at at at
significant risk and we will express
that to the the People's Republic of
China and the most appropriate way
Canada's military isn't alone in such
warnings last year Australia accused the
pilot of a Chinese fighter jet of
releasing flares and chaff which include
small pieces of aluminum which entered
the Australian aircraft's engine and in
May the US accused a Chinese fighter jet
crew of unnecessarily aggressive
behavior during the interception of an
American spy plane over the South China
Sea we're flying off their Coast they uh
they have the right to intercept us um
but we'd like it to be uh at all times
safe and professional Nara Global News
Okinawa
Japan getting more Canadians out of
Harm's Way coming up ottawa's plan to
withdraw non-essential Embassy staff
from
Israel
the Canadian government has been working
to get Canadians in Israel and the West
Bank out of the crisis Zone Canadians
trapped in Gaza though still have no way
out McKenzie gray is in Ottawa tonight
McKenzie yeah Donna Global News has
learned that all non-essential staff
from the Canadian embassy in Israel and
their family members have been ordered
to leave the country according to a
senior government Source now as cenal
staff including the Ambassador are
staying in Tel Aviv to get folks on the
Canadian Armed forces flights to Athen
and there is a big demand for those 2300
Canadians want government help to get
out of Israel and earlier today 21
Canadians were able to get out of the
West Bank via a bus into Jordan and it's
expected there'll be more trips in the
coming days to get the approximately 230
other Canadians whove asked for help out
of the Palestinian
territory and McKenzie the Prime
Minister talked today about the need to
get those hostages in Gaza out what else
did he have to say yeah he started off
his remarks in the House of Commons
talking about Canada's position on Hamas
they are not Freedom Fighters they are
not a
resistance they are
terrorists terrorism is always
indefensible and nothing can justify
hamas's acts of Terror and the killing
maming and Abduction of
civilians but let me also be extremely
clear that Hamas does not represent the
Palestinian people nor their legitimate
aspirations there'll be more discussions
tonight in the House of Commons with a
special late night debate on the issue
and the liberal caucus is also having a
late night strategy session on this
issue Donna all right McKenzie gry in
Ottawa thank you the federal government
has appointed a new special Envoy on
Holocaust remembrance and combating
anti-Semitism and know that we will get
through this very dark period Deborah
lions as a former ambassador to Israel
Afghanistan and the US she'll be tasked
with collecting data and speaking out
for Jewish people when they're attacked
within Canada and abroad Lions replaces
Irwin Cotler a former liberal Justice
Minister who held the position for three
years still ahead the role of Egypt in
this crisis it lies just south of Gaza
is it willing to
help prime minister Justin Trudeau spoke
with the president of Egypt today both
expressed concerns about the blockade of
Gaza and its impact on civilians and
agreed on the need for humanitarian
relief Egypt Israel's neighbor to the
South is trying to deescalate Israel and
Egypt signed a pece treaty back in 1979
and shared a Nobel Peace Prize for it
Egypt's anoir Sadat was the first Arab
leader to make peace with Israel two
years later though he was assassinated
for it now there are concerns from Egypt
that gaza's humanitarian crisis could
spill over into Egypt Eric Sorenson
reports it is in Egypt where convoys of
trucks stand idle ready to transport aid
but the area near the border crossing at
Rafa was bombed last week by Israeli
planes prompting Egypt to close the
crossing Egypt blames Israel for not
reopening it there is pressure on
Egypt's President abdal fat Ali to send
in Aid and to let foreign Nationals out
of Gaza and that's why I prioritize
speaking with president president CC of
Egypt early on last week uh to talk
about that and we will continue to do
everything we can to alleviate the
humanitarian situation on the ground
Egypt said um we're not going to let uh
foreign Nationals out if you if if we
can't let Aid
in Egypt's economy is in Dire Straits
and president alisi has made it clear
Egypt is not prepared to take in what
could total hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians Egypt is reluctant to open
the gate to a mass influx of
Palestinians Egypt and Israel the two
countries that border Gaza want to
contain the humanitarian crisis in
different ways Egypt does not want
things to get worse it wants to
facilitate humanitarian Aid into Gaza
and while it will accept some
Palestinians it does not want a flood of
refugees into Egypt's Sinai Peninsula
Israel wants to block weapons from being
smuggled to Hamas in Gaza but at the
same time is forcing about 1 million
Palestinians to move from northern to
Southern Gaza which increases pressure
to open the Gaza border into Egypt for
more Palestinians many Palestinians
believe Israel's greater goal is to
force them out of Gaza into Egypt it's
in a way uh another nakba catastrophe
where people are being forcibly
ethnically cleansed from uh the
territory and on another hand they don't
even know where to go because there's
nowhere that is safe Egypt will be
Central to any negotiation if Israel and
Hamas can be persuaded to agree to a
ceasefire the Egyptian government has
excellent relations with Israel but it
also has a population that is
overwhelmingly uh uh supportive of the
Palestinians so there is a very very
delicate tight rope walk here but a
ceasefire is not imminent and Egypt's
worst fear is that the humanitarian
crisis will get so bad Egypt will be
inundated with refugees from Gaza Eric
senson Global
News seeking safety nexts the hundreds
of people Sheltering in a Catholic
Church in
[Music]
Gaza it's been more than 3 days since
Israel warned roughly 1 million
Palestinians in Northern Gaza to move
South before its ground Invasion but
with no safe place to go many civilians
have stayed and as Heather uck West
reports some are taking refuge in gaza's
only Catholic
church words of Catholic prayer for
hundreds with no place to
go these images were taken last
Wednesday as the Roman Catholic Church
of Holy Family in Gaza City began to
fill with people seeking Shelter From
the bombs among them the elderly
relatives of a UK Member of Parliament
they went to seek sanctuary in a church
because we're Christian Palestinians and
I'm afraid to say they're still there
because they're too old to go and they
say to me that they have nowhere to go
more than 2 million people live in Gaza
the majority are Muslim and there are
just over a 100 Catholics living in Gaza
City but right now this church is
welcoming all the problem is fuel water
food medicine um things are running
out it's been 3 days since Israel
ordered the evacuation of Northern Gaza
including Gaza City with no safe
corridors and limited places to go I
asked father Gabriel I said are are
people evacuating and he said no we
can't um many of the people as you'll
see in some of the photos are using
wheelchairs Mobility devices um some are
special needs tons and tons of children
the church has never come under attack
before but there is no guarantee those
Gathering here will remain safe there
are no bomb shelters or safe rooms I
texted some of my other friends who live
in Gaza City to go to the church and
they said it's it's not safe to get
there the roads are around the church
are not safe so few ways to find some
semblance of protection the few options
not available to all Heather uck West
Global
News and that is global national for
this Monday I'm Donna freezen we leave
you tonight with the Western Wall in the
old city of Jerusalem a place of prayer
and pilgrimage sacred to the Jewish
people and very close to the al- AXA
mosque and the gold top Dome of the Rock
the third holiest site in Islam thanks
for watching